well every individual should be cheered
up and not be despaired like limit I was
just with the group of people and the
one guy was there and he was like and
people were kind of meditating and it's
going to retreat at our country at the
bed houses country men la mountain
retreat center which is we're trying to
create like a place where people can
feel happy and healthy in the country in
the Catskills in your Woodstock and this
one guy was started reading he just seen
the Al Gore movie and you saw old
panicking you know so listen they're
just join the planets and there's no air
in the water and you just soleus and
flooding and you know the polar bears it
wasn't slipping out and I said look the
only person is destroying the vines
around here now is you I said like your
point is cheer up you know they might
destroy the planet okay they're doing
wrong things okay but by you sitting
here freaking out and spoiling your mood
and forgetting thinking that it's all
like Tuesday all you're doing is having
doomsday today they're not going to
flood everything for another 30 years
why are you having doomsday here and now
and decides it once you totally freaked
out like that you're not going to do
anything but effective about it but if
you're cheerful and joyful maybe you'll
do something so what everybody can do
individually is figure out how to cheer
themselves up in a non-addictive way
addictive way means they give up and
then they buy some zoloft some drugs
that wreck your brain or smoke which
wrecks their lung or drink which wrecks
their liver or whatever other habits
like that which are just sort of
escaping cheer themselves off in some
healthy way you know like reflect a
little bit step back and look at
themselves think about things a little
more carefully and whatever it is
realize that it's their duty to be happy
and positive but that is the one thing
that you really can do in other words
the one
thing that you cannot do is agree to
those in who are currently have power
over us because they have frightened us
because they have convinced us that the
situation is desperate and therefore
they have convinced us that we need them
to protect us that is the one thing you
cannot ascend to in your mind you have
to realize that you are going to be all
right live or die you're going to be
happy even if you have to die it what if
you die why are you going to die angry
or die miserable you know my slogan is
you get to be you be so happy you'd be
so joyful you figure out how to
understand things to be so joyful that
even if they kill you you'll die happy
that's it that's all I have to say to
them and that's what I'm trying to do
myself